here is one of the funniest things I've
seen created around the show as a sort
of meme or satire material and I know
that this was originally about something
meant to make fun of me because I said
the wrong thing according to who knows
who on the Internet
doesn't matter it is hilarious remember
the movie airplane I believe it's from
1984 82 1980 1980 okay the movie
airplane from 1980 with the great Leslie
Nielsen one of the one of my favorite
movies of the genre and of the genre I
consider the airplane movies The Naked
Gun movies Austin Powers movies that
style of movie there is a scene in that
movie where passengers have to sort of
slap sense into another passenger on the
plane who's freaking out I don't know
who made this but a twitter user named
Raj endo tweeted it out maybe rejent Oh
made it maybe not
and it says David Pakman realizes that
he's fake news my face has been
superimposed onto the freaking out
passenger in the airplane movie and
people are coming up and slapping me in
the face it is really well done I'm
going to play the clip if you're only
listening you'll get the audio the video
really is what makes it check it out
this is just this is proof that that
some people have way way too much time
on their hands yeah especially if you
have to go frame-by-frame
I don't know how little work on I don't
understand the logistics of it if it had
to be done frame by frame it is stunning
anyway let's take a look at it here
absolutely brilliant now Pat is that
this movie was produced long before you
were born before I was well but long
before you were born is this a movie
you're familiar with no and I'm actually
pretty disturbed by it really yeah and I
didn't know that you flew United
Airlines um that's good I like that clip
how long were you thinking of that one
about an hour ago
that's a good one I like that uh make a
note folks it is a big day for producer
Pat that may be one of your better lines
on the show I think I do concur with
that one okay so this is pretty good
quality right I mean this is this is a
great satirical parody and I don't care
that someone was trying to criticize me
on the Internet I'm used to that if you
do it in a clever way you'll probably
make it onto the show if it's this good
it makes me want to watch the movie
because I haven't seen this before it
reminds me of that quote the beatings
will continue and until morale improves
yeah alright so check that out if you're
if you listen check out the video of it